let's check in with let's check in with
Patrick from Indiana Patrick what's
going on buddy hey how you doing good so
uh sorry about that a jimmy dore call a
while back i know you lost some members
because of that that was my my last call
sorry hold on hold on we can we've got
you we've got your volume at the max and
I can still barely hear you you said
something about a jimmy dore call no I I
just wanted to apologize for my jimmy
dore call and you're losing well back I
know that that was a point of contention
some of your listeners and I just wanted
to uh say sorry but that's not my oh no
problem you'll be getting an invoice
from us soon go ahead my question
actually uh pertains to everyone's Mandy
Moore Howard Schultz and I just kind of
wanted to get your take on why the media
and the press gives such deference to
billionaires especially when they try to
enter the political arena like Howard
Schultz immediately has all this
legitimacy it gets to go on any show he
wants and there was actually a segment
on Stephanie ruhle show where Jeff Stein
called into question his presidential
run and and said that he was probably
doing it for self-serving interest
because of Ocasio Cortez's proposed
marginal tax rate on him so I just
wanted to get your take on why it has so
much deference to billionaires who
decide to well because we live in a
country where wealth is equivalent with
being good and being smart essentially
right and I know people will say David
that's not true look at all these
commies who say billionaires are evil
there's almost no communist in the
United States they have no significant
voice whatsoever and questioning
inequality also is not an indication
that you think the rich people are
necessarily bad people that exists but
big picture the media and political
apparatus in this country value money as
a proxy to figuring out whether someone
is intelligent skilled or a good person
so that that's like the one sentence
answer now getting beyond that there is
this bias towards sensationalism and the
idea of show
as not just another Democratic candidate
he's not kirsten gillibrand for example
he is doing something different he's
saying I would be running as an
independent
and of course implicit in that is the
way in which he could end up helping
Donald Trump there is sort of like logo
philia in the sense of corporate logos
like Starbucks and people who
effectively are praying at the altar of
Starbucks he is the founder of that is
also in a sort of revered and privileged
position so it's all that stuff I mean
it's just it's corporate ah Chrissy and
it's it's capitalism and that's that's
why um and one more quick follow-up if I
may um he was on Morning Joe and I
believe Mika Brzezinski asked him how
much a box of Cheerios costs I believe
this was this morning and he had no idea
yeah so I'm just wondering if he'll ever
get any backlash for something that is
frankly idiotic or not you won't having
a ballpark estimate of how much of box
of Cheerios cause well you know what
then I'm anything that let's do let's
talk about that for a second that's
interesting so there's a segment you can
find on YouTube and I encourage people
to check it out we're Ellen DeGeneres
has Bill Gates on her show and she plays
a game with him where he just has to
guess how much things cost and it's like
a box of frozen pizza treats and some
Tide Pods for washing clothes or
whatever and he has no idea and I get
the game right it's like he's so out of
touch I've heard Howard Stern be asked
by Robin Quivers do you have any idea
what a gallon of milk costs right now
and the guy has no idea I think that it
should be concerning to us in the sense
that we don't want people who are in
positions of power that are completely
out of touch but that alone I mean
listen I'd rather have Bill Gates than
Howard Schultz I think as president of
the United States why because I think
Bill Gates his areas of expertise and
the intelligence that he's developed as
just an intelligent guy in the world
would make him a better president on
policy than Howard Schultz I get the
game but I don't know how I mean you
know yeah the guy's out of touch we know
that well that's pretty much yeah what I
wanted to ask you so thanks for taking
my call
all right really appreciate it Patrick
good to hear from you we're going to
a quick break if you're on hold don't
hang off because we are taking more
calls after the break I just have to
switch sneak in a quick break and we
will be right back and back to the phone
standby